comment organiser les examens et
partielles à l'université alors que les
sites des Tanneurs à Tours est toujours
bloqué par des étudiants pour protester
contre la réforme des retraites
l'université a proposé d'autres sites
pour les examens qui ont lieu depuis le
17 avril les étudiants se disent peu
informés et inquiets le site des
Tanneurs devrait être de nouveau
accessibles à partir de ce mercredi
il y a une il y a un stress
compréhensible mais on la délocalisation
se fait en les informant en amont et le
réseau de transport en commun de la
ville de Tours permet de se rendre sur
les différents sites sans problème
c'est déjà très stressant mais en plus
de pas savoir où est-ce que ça va se
passer pas savoir s'ils vont avoir lieu
ou pas ça rajoute une un énorme stress
et vu que j'étais à Grandmont là ce
matin et que d'habitude je suis au
tanneur j'ai du trajet en plus donc
beaucoup moins de temps à réviser en
quelque sorte du temps perdu en fait
parce qu'on sait pas où on va devoir
aller c'est des bâtiments qu'on connaît
pas forcément donc ça rajoute un stress
supplémentaire de savoir si on va
pouvoir trouver la salle à temps etc le
fait de devoir aller de l'autre côté
tour c'est pas toujours pratique on doit
se lever beaucoup plus tôt c'est
fatiguant en période de révision tout ça
donc franchement la délocalisation je
pense pas que ça a été la meilleure
solution